that's because of the post up to boyan  uh  great call by coach schneider posting  him up the first play the first post up  of the game  in my recollection he gets one and then  how about the second post  up he gets it out to a wide open shooter  round with oh mitchell losing his  balance  gets the bucket and a foul is called  oh yeah now he's getting tense so first  of all  he shakes a man to the floor now he's  going to shake mitchell to the floor  mitchell doesn't like this if we show  after the play look at this  brown's going to pat him on the butt if  we could let it go just a little bit  longer because this  play is going to happen the rest of the  game the energy in the game is about to  change  because of this play he pats him on the  butt and he smacks him on the arm  i'm telling you right now basketball  fans watch these two  the rest of the game the intensity just  woke up on that play  chris you sound like